[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III stage I am Mike McCarty here as
always with Lucy James no we are also
joined by Justin creative director on
skull and bones thank you so much for
joining us Justin thanks very much for
having me it's exciting to be able to
talk about Skull and Bones and show the
world exactly what we're trying to bring
to life yeah so tell us a little bit
about what you got to show off at
Ubisoft conference and what you're
showing on the show floor here and
everything well I think in general
Ubisoft is proud to create games that
are worlds that you can explore and
experience and lose yourself in and
skull and bones is exactly that you know
our game is set during the twilight of
the Golden Age of piracy it's a time
when pirates are looking for a new place
to hunt and leaving the Caribbean the
fishbowl of the Caribbean is something
much bigger the biggest hunting grounds
that you know pirates have ever been
able to hunt in the most competitive but
also the most rewarding and what we're
showing this year is what we call the
hunting grounds it's a shared and
competitive world where people can come
together either solo or form a gang of
pirates and hunt and terrorize the trade
routes it's just a good opportunity for
us to show the essence of what our game
is yeah we were just chatting beforehand
and you were talking about kind of
designing a game with social media
streaming specifically in mind and
allowing people to come across something
that they'll be able to like talk about
like these emergent things that you you
stumble upon do you talk about how that
influenced that does that mean labonz we
want it we you know obviously we believe
in storytelling right but we want to
empower our players to tell their own
stories and give them a canvas where
they can paint their own pirate legend
it's it's the foundation of what Skull
and Bones is we have a system that's
called fortunes and what fortunes gives
us is an opportunity to create a
different experience for players in
every game mode every single single time
they log in something that's unique to
that experience is a preset system that
allows you to change the conflicts
between factions the weather the ocean
itself the wind the power of the wind
and the trade routes so every single
time a player comes to a hunting ground
he's going to get his fortune read learn
about the state of the world and then
make the preparations that he needs to
do to become an effective hunter in that
session so how do I go about if I wanted
to log on and play how do I go
jumping into the hunting grounds so
you'll start in your hideout which is
your own base that you have or your
pirate gangs kind of setup in you'll
meet historical characters they're
inspired characters visit the tavern
listen to shanties you know all the
things you would expect in a pirate's a
layer and you'll customize your ship or
ships add the right weapons that you
want to add recruit the right crew that
gives you the best opportunity for
success customize and create your own
your own flag your emblems your look
your feel and then you set sail into the
ocean you'll also have an opportunity to
get Intel about the world because for us
information is as valuable as treasure
and using that information feeling smart
is something we want the player to feel
every single time they sail into the
world and what kind of playtesting did
you have to do to account for the PvP
aspects I mean like the the PvP focus of
the game right I mean like we think
Ubisoft naval combat we look back at
Assassin's Creed 3 Black Flag and then
Odyssey has a big focus on it now but
this Skull and Bones specifically has
PvP what challenges does that bring it
our focus is PvP PvE so we give players
you know an objective that they define
we don't tell them good to go out and
and say do this do this do that we say
what do you want to accomplish do you
want to level up your ships you want to
recruit better crew do you want to
socialize do you want to hunt other
players you decide all of those things
and we do it in a way where all of the
resources are in a fixed amount in the
world so if you think about like in
nature if you're hunting you know if
you're a wolf you're competing against
other Wolf's for the prey right it's the
same thing in our world we create these
conflicts where everyone has the same
needs everyone has the same way to fuel
their progression at the top and that
fuels progression but it also fuels
opportunities to ally and to meet other
pirate gangs with the same exact
motivations to group together to defend
each other against other pirates and the
empires so if we've meet other pirates
other players and we decide to ally with
them what kind of matchmaking is that to
make sure that we stay together it's
like a party up system any kind of Lobby
we want to create a fluidity within the
world so that if I meet someone I can
temporarily form an alliance and then we
can go our own ways or one of us could
betray the other in
I'm not that kind of player but we
definitely have them on our team and
also to form permanent bonds you know
create a group of pirates of gang of
pirates that has the same objectives
that works season after season for
rewards you know to fuel them they're
their own motivations their own
ambitions to become too big to fail and
you were just mentioning you calling it
PvP yeah how do you it's so say I'm not
like super into multiplayer games I can
skullenbones still it could be for me if
I'm jumping in yeah I mean I I'm very
conscious of that we have lots of
players on our team and in the community
who may be a little averse to fighting
and you know we are shared world you're
never alone there's always other players
and the opportunity to meet other
players but you decide how you interact
with them we give you tools to be able
to do that properly you have a Crows
Nest which allows you to get a 360 view
of the world you have a spyglass which
lets you get information about the other
ships to identify threats whether
they're human threats or whether they're
npc threats and then take action to
engage that player exactly how you want
you can hail a player tell them you're
not you know that you want a group that
you're not a threat or you can disguise
yourself as you know a Portuguese
merchants for example change your flag
sneak up on him and you know just attack
them we think those moments are really
really cool we're seeing people play it
every day and you know we want people to
have the right ability along the way so
for example skill determines the outcome
in our game so it's not I'm a higher
level than you so I win it's it's about
how you're able to determine the outcome
by being good using the wind learning
the weapon systems and becoming a more
effective predator in pvp and PVE just
to piggyback off that is there gonna be
any weight obviously you gonna have
people who are gonna agree it's an
online game it's what some people do is
what people some people do for fun and
they can do me any no punishments
necessarily but ways to discourage
players from griefing ubisoft in general
takes toxicity very seriously we want to
have a very inclusive world in
skullenbones we have a community that's
live right now on reddit's our subreddit
our discord and our lie
you know official forums so we're
listening to the community understanding
what their concerns are we have play
tests we play every single day to
understand what those challenges are and
we want to enable the tools and the
community to be able to counter that
toxicity the most important thing is to
create positive social interactions
whether they're competitive or
cooperative so I I'm sure you can't talk
about other games I get that but I don't
want to put you on the spot but so see
if thieves released recently and I'm
like last year during e3 it was like oh
there's a several pirate games that are
about to come out well not about to come
out but on the horizon see if these
released and it was clear that there is
a huge audience for pirate games right
now or at least the fantasy of being a
pirate is there any additional pressure
on the team now that see if thieves is
out I know you're it's being reductive
to say they're both similar games
because they're very different game I
understand yeah exactly what your point
is personally I'm a big fan of rares
games you know and I have friends
working you know with it with the title
and I'm very happy to see the community
have that passion for pirate games it's
something that we're happy about we are
listening to the community we're aware
of challenges that that other games have
had and their launches and for us it's
about making sure that we're being very
transparent with our community
we're understood we're understanding
that we're creating something very
specific to our strengths as a developer
at Ubisoft Singapore and we're creating
a game with depth replayability long
legs we're a live service game we have
dedicated server architecture to create
a safe you know secure and fun
environment for people to play
competitions should be about skill it
shouldn't be about a latency or or you
know some of the other challenges you
have when you're not creating a
dedicated server architecture and the
other thing that we look at is what is
the essence of the pirate fantasy and
it's piracy it's the attack and robbing
of ships at sea it's being on the high
seas at the helm of a powerful ship
that's really what we're trying to focus
on yeah there have been very few times
if any that a game has really nailed the
pirate fantasy that you guys feel
pressured to finally I mean a Ubisoft we
I worked on Assassin's Creed 4 Black
Flag and the art team at Ubisoft
Singapore worked on a lot of the
Caribbean we
worked on the ac3 linear missions the
naval missions and even AC syndicate and
the River Thames we're water tech
specialists we are pirates special as we
have the passion for it and I don't know
if you know but in Singapore we have a
lot of guys on the team who actually
have pirate blood running through their
veins we have guys who have a historical
you know stake in this it's something
that helped shape the nations in in the
Indian Ocean and in Singapore Malaysia
Indonesia specifically so it's an area
we're hugely passionate about I think
the people are hungry for pirate games
and we want to make sure that we're
listening to what they're expecting and
being very transparent about what our
game is and what we're great at speaking
of like you buff Studios obviously look
like a lot of times you will have
multiple Studios working on one game but
it's not just that like at the moment
we've seen in Assassin's Creed Odyssey
there's gonna be more naval combat there
was some in origins are you guys all
still working and talking together when
it comes to the main line that Sussman's
Creek gets working at this company has
been really amazing for me I've been at
Ubisoft for five plus years and the
collaboration between studios and
projects is amazing
without that collaboration we wouldn't
be able to share knowledge experience
challenges and we're trying to share
what we're learning about making a game
like skullenbones with other studios at
Ubisoft Singapore we actually work on
Assassin's Creed as well as you know
skull and bones so there's a lot of
collaboration learnings but what we're
trying to do is something very unique we
have a fully replicated physics based
ocean every single player on our servers
experiences the same ocean the same
physics the same wind and for us we know
that we're doing something unique but of
course we share that knowledge we work
on our game the demo is worked on by
Ubisoft blue bye-bye blue by Ubisoft
Chengdu obviously I've been in Singapore
and Ubisoft Philippines as well you
mentioned that you're you're creating
the game obviously like Ubisoft support
just games post-launch and you said
you're kind of like are you looking at
other games such as like Monster Hunter
destiny
are you gonna be planning on updating
this game with like weekly events or is
that gonna be that kind of post
launchers are gonna be traditional DLC
do you have you announced plans like
that yeah we won't come to to unroll and
unravel season after season so we're
always giving players you know content
that's not partitioned off or that's not
you know segmenting the our audience
will release new regions in fact one of
our partners is working you know very
very hard on making sure that we can
have that sort of content ubisoft sofia
and and for us it's it's about giving
players new ships new content new
cosmetics new cruise to recruit new
regions to explore so that year after
year season after season they have new
challenges new pirate Kings
legends of the sea to take down all of
those things are what we want players to
to see and feel like there's always
something new to engage in and that
they're gonna be missing out if they're
not competing in those seasons and also
a lot of the times a games as a service
are supplemented by loot boxes and
microtransactions can you talk about
whether they'll be in school I mean
people look at our demo and they're like
oh loot boxes but loot is a central part
of the fantasy it's something you earn
when you're sailing when you sink ships
when you recover a dig up treasure it's
a little early for us to talk about our
monetization strategy or how we want to
engage players but what we want to make
sure is that people know that they can
earn the things in the game that we're
not partitioning off how we unload our
content to players and every season they
can they can compete for those things
themselves
we don't want them to be pay to win or
anything like that we're we're all
gamers on our team and when we see those
sort of things happen in the industry we
take it personally and we've committed
to our audience and our community to
give them a way that skill determines
the outcome if you win a fight it's
because you're better it's because you
learn how to use that particular ship or
that particular weapon and you equip the
right crew for the right situation
Ubisoft recently is kind of built or the
Ubisoft individual Ubisoft Studios and
use ops as publisher have kind of
recently built built up a reputation for
really good post post launch support
Rainbow six seeds release three updates
all the time they don't want to segment
the audience for honor is going strong
into their second year now the new TLC
is great yeah and are you looking at
other Ubisoft Studios or is there
anything you're kind of like
cherry-picking borrowing from
that are influencing I mean we have to
take best-in-class we have to look at
how the communities are reacting to
particular DLCs or mechanisms to engage
the community you know the community
directly so we do apply those learnings
as well as using you know bi data you
know the metrics that they're getting
from their performance and understanding
what people like what they don't like
what they resist what they embrace and
applying those lessons yeah we're being
very proactive we don't develop in a
bubble we look at other games in the
industry as well to make sure that we're
you know giving people the best possible
experience when they come online we want
to keep them for a decade or more you
know skullenbones is not a game that
that I want people to walk in play for
20 hours and feel like they're done I
want them to feel like what's next what
region or even explore next
what pirate kingpin is going to be in my
face trying to take me down and and how
can I get new ships new RPG archetypes
for the ships that I play what's new its
I wanted to constantly be something that
players are looking forward to what what
is you know coming down the pipe for
Skull and Bones speaking of players
obviously you mentioned that you have a
quite a rabid fan base already write it
on forums how do you incorporate what
they want to see in the game compared to
you know the cool game design that you
guys want to implement well you know
we're very passionate about the game
we're building we know that we have
expertise both in the tech and and the
the IP itself and the genre but we do
engage the community every single day
I'm active on our forums I talked to our
core group of fans they're called the
keepers of the code and they're more
than just fans of our game they're
people who are giving us active feedback
letting us know what the community buzz
is working on not just evangelizing but
sharing what the message is of skull and
bones and also giving us very honest and
sometimes brutal feedback about the
decisions we make in our game and it's
important that we you know embrace that
feedback and we adjust the trajectory of
our game to account for that and still
also maintain a very pure vision about
what we want to do what we believe in
and what we know to be the best possible
experience awesome well Justin anything
we didn't touch on that you want yeah
absolutely we have live phases that are
coming on like I said the community is
super important to us you can register
for those live phases at Skull and Bones
game.com we know we launched in 2019 and
for us we have to use this time right
now and those live phases
understand exactly what our game is
where we're heading and get that
feedback that's gonna make the game the
best pirate game that's ever been made
awesome well Justin thank you so much
for you guys for having yeah enjoy the
rest of the show and getting
congratulations that you got the game
playable and everything on the show
floor if you're watching from home do
not go anywhere we are about to dive
into an interview about sony's dreams
see you then
[Music]